thank you all hello everybody my name is
John Mulaney it's very nice to be here
it's very nice to be out of the house at
night in general for me I actually quit
drinking a few months ago because uh
yeah thank you for your support but what
had happened was I got to a point where
I was blacking out every time I drank
and I went to talk to my doctor about it
and he said that it wasn't that I was
drinking too much it's just that after
you have a couple major blackouts your
brain will black out easier and easier
automatically so I could like go to a
bar and have like one or two beers and
my brain would be like okay I see where
this is headed why don't we just power
down now and then get restarted sometime
tomorrow morning he's always weird when
I'd go out for the night
with like some money and then blackout
and wake up with no money it was even
weirder though when I would go out for
the night with some money blackout and
wake up with more money because that
means that I earned money that means
that I traded goods and/or services
which is scary
but sometimes I'd almost be proud of it
I'd be like wow I turned twenty dollars
into a hundred dollars I am a financial
wizard like I'd like to give people
money advice but I don't know how that
would go they'd be like John I'm looking
to get rich quick and I'd be like well
have you tried mixing daiquiris with
ambien they're like does that work I'm
like it didn't not work
stay home now and I watch Law & Order
that that is my favorite show
I realized Law & Order was my favorite
show when I was in my fourth consecutive
hour of Law & Order bigger this better
be my favorite otherwise I have a
problem best thing about Law & Order
though is that the same things happen on
every episode every single I was like
watch it next time in the beginning of
every Law & Order when the detectives
are first like interviewing witnesses
for the case the people they talk to
always act like it's no big deal to be
questioned by homicide detectives
they're very casual about it
there's been like a double rape and
murder and they're talking to some guy
who's just like Tony Ramirez yeah
remember him used to work here Tuesday's
right it's like dude people have died
you can't stop unloading crates for a
few seconds
how often you talk to homicide
detectives and then they'll let some
detail about the case go that they don't
even realize is important I'd be like
well did he say where he was going I
don't know he said something about going
to the knife store yeah pertains to the
stabbing investigation I grew up
Catholic had to go to Catholic schools
we had bought yes sure we had we had
Bible study class in the school I went
to every week Bible study class and a
one Bible story I've always remembered
is the story of King Solomon and the
baby I don't know if you guys remember
this one King Solomon he's the wise king
of Israel and two women bring him a baby
and they say we both claim that this is
our baby what are you gonna do and
Solomon says well we will cut the baby
down the middle and the first woman says
oh okay woman says no don't cut the baby
down the middle and Solomon says AHA
congratulations you have proven yourself
to be the real mother a couple of things
with that
who is this first woman that sounds like
a good idea has just stolen a bait she
stole a baby and then it's the first
inquest she's like look I'll take what I
can get can I get the lamb I'll take the
legs she can have the top part
she's so whacked out she calls the head
the top part
secondly that he knew it was the real
mother cuz she knew not to cut a baby in
half oh I think most people would come
to that conclusion like if I was walking
down the street and I saw someone about
to saw a child in half I'd be like hey
why don't you not do that oh you must be
the father
[Applause]